actually is with us in Dallas Texas hi
actually welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
thank you Dave for taking my call I
appreciate it certainly how can I help
so I'm thinking way for our head I have
a 16 month old and I'm trying to start
figuring out how to introduce money to
him because he is getting into the
toddler years I don't know when to
introduce is my first baby so he
recommend good for you mom well done
well what we did at the Ramsey house was
we just tied teaching money to teaching
life you're going to teach this one
responsibility you're going to teach him
to do his homework brushes teeth comb
his hair wear a belt all those kinds of
things right I mean we're going to teach
the little guy how to be a person that's
your job as a parent is to give him life
skills money is one of those life skills
but the fun thing is it ties to
character qualities that you're trying
to build inside your child integrity
work ethic the ability to delay pleasure
these are character qualities are people
who succeed at anything so it's a great
teaching area to work in so I just make
sure you don't get overzealous and and
keep it calm and age-appropriate by that
I mean the smaller they are there's just
lots and lots of grace so let me give
you an example he's 16 so he's walking
and chattering maybe just a little bit
right yeah 16 months okay okay so have
you had him pick up any of his own toys
yet working on it okay that's generally
what happens with that age right
it's a toddler so that you know so at
our house when they were that age if
they put one toy in the box while we
saying clean up clean up clean up put
your toys away or whatever the little
zone was right and we put the rest of
toys in the box and they put one or two
toys in we called that a huge touchdown
that's a success when you're sixteen
months agreed oh yeah and lots of praise
and look at you you're the best room
cleaner in the world you just cleaned up
all these toys I'm so proud of you
meanwhile you did 90% of it agreed so at
fast forward a year from now that's
probably still about where you're gonna
be only they may be your pick
up a little more percentage but you're
still in there helping and you're still
praising and praising and praising you
might a year from now give them a dollar
and wad it up and put it in a clear jar
so it takes up more room in the clear
jar right that's why we watered it up
because they're very visual when they're
small right yeah that's kind of stuff we
did and so it was like all I was trying
to do is real early I'm not send them to
the salt mines at 3 years old ok but
real early I'm trying to teach work
ethic and I'm beginning to teach the
emotional connection between work and
money
I meet 54 year-olds who don't have that
emotional connection they're still
trying to figure out how they don't have
to work you have to work that's a life
skill that mums and dads should teach
their kids how to work and how to work
hard when this country was at its
greatest people grew up on the farm and
they had to work and it work hard and
then when they went to any other career
they knew how to work and they knew how
to work hard and most of us including me
do not have an agrarian background and
we've lost a little something in that
process but I still taught my kids to
work I still don't work hard I was still
taught to work
I still taught to work hard even though
I grew up in the subdivision ok so you
can do that and we're not try again
we're not trying to send them to the
salt mines when they're three years old
but by the time they're 16 I want
something breaking a sweat because
they're useless otherwise if all they
know how to do is play Gameboy on the TV
or whatever it is a Nintendo and eat
Doritos you're a child abuser you didn't
give your kid any life skills yeah they
need to be doing something because there
ain't no jobs out there well there's a
few jobs for gamers but not many it's
not a career field ok so they need to
have something they know how to work
that's the thing and then once they
learn to work then as they get a little
bit older let's say we're up to five or
six years old now this takes a while
we're not gonna be too harsh this is a
lot of grace with the baby's okay mainly
99% encouragement but the time they're
six or so we're probably going to break
this down we did it our house into three
envelopes you work you get paid for
specific chores you put a chore chart on
the refrigerator and you got a dollar
for five different chores that week at
the end of week you got your $5 if you
did them all
but you weren't on allowance at our
house allowances a welfare we don't do
allowance your own commission or get
paid don't work don't get paid by the
way everybody who has a jobs on
commission try not going to work for
four weeks see if they pay you nobody
gets paid but they don't go to work so
you get what you do your work you get
paid now once you get the five dollars
in your hand then we spread it out into
three envelopes a giving envelope
because we want to teach generosity who
there's a great character quality once
it gets to have oh and then we want to
put some of the saving envelopes so they
can save up and buy their first car and
then we want to put some in their
spending envelope so you can teach them
how to do wise and control to mature
spending not frivolous impulsive crazy
spending if you could teach your kid how
to save give work and spend wisely you
have been a rock star parent I'll send
you the book called smart money smart
kids teaches parents how to do just that
Rachel Cruise and I wrote it as a number
one bestseller my gift to you
[Music]